yeah i mean i could have tried and
no i don't know there was no way i was
winning that anyway
i mean i was two pawns down and i had no
time so
i should uh quit yapping
i'll just play okay he means business
he's already made his first move
that's what i know from this game these
games that whenever
i get to to the next and my opponent has
already made the first move
then they mean business so let me go
for just something something normal
and speaking of normal he plays the
the italian and indeed what could be
more
what could be more normal than that
uh okay whatever we'll do h6
and we'll go a6
and just play very normally
of course wesley is somebody who whose
style is
well suited to positional play but i'm
i'm not worried about that i feel like i
can also come
compete well in that department
so i'm going for the standard plan
of just going [ __ ] v6 and exchanging
exchanging those and then
trying to get some some play in the
center
i had this against ding and he played c4
i believe
then i went to a5 and we had ourselves a
complicated fight
uh i guess d4 is sort of more
normal i go knight to six
in order not to trap my own rook
let's see for interesting
i should be into into details here but
evidently i'm not
uh wesley really likes
positions with uh
with some space advantage
i mean who doesn't but
i don't really know what i can do about
it let me go a5
whether it's good or bad it's
at least throws a bit of a spanner and
it works
okay i guess it didn't because he went
v5 immediately
um
i guess i can take with some more
credibility
with the rook
rook e8 i think and if not f5 i've got
knight g5
for the best
a3
very logical stuff
so no pun intended
uh bishop c5 rook g3 bishop b4 and
knight f5 is happening
that's probably no good
oh
this may have been an important mess by
me
yeah i really don't like this now
where's my where's my car
okay um yeah it's
clearly i must have studied my game
against uh anishkeri and
realized that i cannot kind of play
against the italian
[Music]
okay we'll take it just to try and get
some
at least some semblance of stability
here
rookie six i don't know next
it's a bit yucky
i'm hoping that after like ruchi 3 queen
7
it's not that easy to friend to
uh to protect everything okay now after
okay let's go b6 first trying to be a
bit flexible
then maybe knight d7 to c5
although he is gonna try and run me over
as quickly as i can
but now at the very least i'm not
getting mated
with rook g3 and so on so
i'm getting getting mated this way
instead
that is of course a bit unpleasant
okay i'll go knight c5 pretend like
everything's fine
it's all good it really isn't but
i'll pretend obviously f5 can be met by
knight e5
h4 i'll go on queen d7
just knight f3
yeah this is unpleasant okay i'll go
i'll go queen d7
and beg for mercy
oh f5 is really strong now
yeah f5 is reached right 95 95
d5 mission c5 then rook d1
and rook d5 i'm getting squashed
positionally so i have to sack the
exchange after f5
95 95 rookie 5 and then d5
just hope for hope for the best my
knight is pretty strong so i think he
blinks it's not uh
it's not a foreign conclusion that i'm
losing that
if bishop c5 yeah this one i was not so
worried about
because i get to a pause on the d file
if you if you had time for
oh yes rook d5 but is this really so
scary
first of all i can take it i don't think
i should but i can go
97 and then this is this point
i miss that nicer blade okay
i'll go f6 this is
very dicey now
yeah this is certainly no good
the usual story down on time and a
terrible position
now is usually when i start to excel
doesn't have an immediate kill at the
very least
okay i'll go h5 not to worry about the
check
okay so
um okay i'll take it
update 97
is this really silver
oh yes yeah this is really is so bad
yeah this is just wins
a rook d6 it's even better
oh boy oh boy
maybe i could have gone king e8 instead
of fought on
96 would be seven that's really bad as
well
okay but that was
that was thoroughly deserved